When I think about where do we go from
here, I think about where I come from
which is the great south side of Chicago.
Where I was born and raised I attended K
through 12 public schools. I also
attended a great public institution for
undergrad where I met Diane Penderhughes, an African-American female
political scientist who changed my life
her motivation encouraged me to pursue a
PhD and to enter a career in academia.
Now at UCLA I've become the first
african-american female and the first
woman of color in the political science
department to earn tenure and promotion.
I teach with an understanding that
higher education changes socioeconomic
status but not just for our students but
possibly for their communities and
generations to come so where do we go
from here? Well we'll continue to
motivate and inspire our students each
day and moreover. We'll continue to be
motivated and inspired by our students
at UCLA. In short where do we go from
here? We'll continue to teach our hearts
out at UCLA.